(dramatic music)
- When I tell people I'm
a pro-foosball player
there's always a look
of like astonishment.
I get laughter sometimes too,
what, I didn't know there was
tournaments for that, foosball?
Yeah that's the one
that's, that's what I do.
(dramatic music)
Foosball's not just a, a barroom game.
It's a competitive sport that's played
at a professional level by
people all around the world.
It's like a hand-to-hand combat, you're,
you're standing this close you know,
you're standing three feet
away from your opponent,
and it's almost like you're in a fight,
you're battling against each other.
I come from a, a long
line of foosball players.
I got into foosball because of my dad.
He played in the, the golden era,
the 1970s when there was
a million dollar tour.
I've been playing for 20 years now.
So for the first 10 to
12 years of my career
I would practice on a table at home.
It would be complete repetition.
Over and over and over.
Every player in here can
execute a shot or a pass.
But it's a matter of
constructing a solid game plan.
It's like a, a game of
chess on the mental side.
It, it could be pretty taxing.
Physically by the end of the weekend you,
you're sore, your hands are sore,
your feet are sore so you
have to be in decent shape.
I always got a, a sweat band on my arm
just in case I get into a, a heated match
I gotta, you know, wipe my brow, so.
I go to the World Cup, which is basically
our version of the Olympics,
and I compete on Team USA.
I do believe it should be in the Olympics.
Our only problem is the fact that
there's not a standardized foosball table.
And I'll do whatever it takes to,
for the sport to reach that next level.
Bottom line is it makes me happy
that this is what I do
and, yeah I love it.